.
* Straûenlärm *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Untertitelfarben:
Sophie Lavaud
Daway Sangay
* Französisch *
(Übersetzung) Mein Traum ist,
alle 14 Achttausender zu besteigen.
Es gibt nur drei Frauen
auf der Welt,
die das erreicht haben.
Dieser Traum
wird immer mehr greifbar.
* Fernöstliche Musik *
Irgendwann war mir klar:
Das ist es und nichts anderes.
Bis heute stand ich auf elf.
Der Dhaulagiri
zieht nicht viele Leute an.
In der Regel heiût es,
dass der Berg schwierig ist.
Das Wichtigste ist herunterzukommen,
damit man die Geschichte
erzählen kann.
Guten Tag.
In dem Thamel.
- Okay.
Wie viel?
500. Ein guter Preis.
350.
Ich liebe Kathmandu.
Es ist ein sympathisches Chaos.
Hallo!
Ah, Tensing!
Ich sitze im Taxi Richtung Thamel.
Können wir vielleicht
nach dem Mittagessen vorbeikommen?
Okay. Danke. Bis später.
Ich mache recht viele Dinge
zusätzlich zu den Expeditionen.
Es ist immer so: das, das, das.
Ich fahre ins Stadtzentrum,
um da Billy Bierling zu treffen.
Sie führt die Himalaya-Datenbank.
Vor und nach jeder Expedition
macht sie ein Briefing.
Und jetzt gehts
um die Dhaulagiri-Expedition
von diesem Frühjahr.
* Spannende Musik *
Ich kenne den Dhaulagiri,
ich war schon zweimal da.
Das hier ist der dritte Versuch.
Beim ersten Mal
hatten wir Pech mit dem Wetter.
Der Jetstream kam sehr früh.
Am 1. Oktober gab es
schon 100 km/h Wind am Gipfel.
Dann ist es unmöglich.
Und 2019 musste ich
wegen meiner Mutter heimfahren.
Also ja, langsam wird er
ein vertrauter Kumpel.
Guten Tag.
Sangay ist der Sherpa,
mit dem ich arbeite.
Er ist mein Kletterpartner.
Wir waren zusammen auf dem K2,
der Annapurna,
Kangchendzönga, Gasherbrum I.
Das hier ist
die siebte gemeinsame Expedition.
Hast du die Liste mit den Sherpas?
Wir brauchen sie für das Briefing.
(Englisch)
Kann ich dich umarmen?
Sicher! Hallo.
Hallo, wie geht es dir?
Also, Sophie. Wieder eine Expedition.
Jetzt hast du also eine
Frauen-Expedition zusammengestellt.
Ja.
Und wie heiût die Expedition?
Internationale Frauen-Expedition
Dhaulagiri 2021.
Genau.
Und du leitest sie.
Ja.
Wie hoch ist euer Basislager
am Dhaulagiri?
4'700.
Lager 1 ist irgendwo hier.
Lager 2 ist am Fuû des Grates.
Lager 2 ist heikel,
wegen den Lawinen.
Ja, Lawinen.
Auch im Lager 3
ist sehr wenig Platz.
Ja.
Es gibt zwei Lager 3.
Ein tieferes und ein höheres.
Das tiefere ist auf 7'000,
das obere auf 7'200 Meter.
Okay. Ihr schaut,
wie die Bedingungen sind.
Ja. Je nach Bedingungen.
Aber wir machen nur drei Höhenlager.
- Ja, nur drei.
Und wirst du Sauerstoff verwenden?
Wie immer. Ich nehme ihn mit und
schaue, ob ich ihn brauche. - Okay.
Alle anderen sind in der Datenbank.
* Sie prosten sich
auf Französisch und Englisch zu. *
Auf den Dhaulagiri.
Das dritte Mal bringt Glück.
- Das dritte Mal! Lass uns sehen.
Ich ziehe meinen Hut vor Sophie,
wenn ich sehe, in welcher kurzen Zeit
sie auf elf Achttausendern war.
Wir haben
etwa zeitgleich angefangen.
Ich war auf sechs Achttausendern
und sehe, wie Sophie ...
Annapurna, K2, Broad Peak.
Also wenn ich
von einem Achttausender runterkomme,
dann brauche ich erst mal Ruhe.
Dann muss ich mich erholen.
Und ich denke mir immer:
Wahnsinn, wie Sophie das macht.
Keine weiteren Fragen?
Nein.
Aber ich werde mehr Fragen haben,
wenn ihr zurückkommt.
Und ich habe auch die Entwicklung
schon ein bisschen mit gesehen.
Sie war damals auch am Everest
mit Kobler und Partner, als Kundin,
oder als Gast, wie man sagt.
Ja, und jetzt hat sie
hier ihre eigene Expedition.
Und hat diese Frauen-Expedition
zum Dhaulagiri zusammengestellt.
Ich muss wirklich sagen,
ich ziehe meinen Hut. Klasse.
Das Spezielle am Dhaulagiri ist,
dass die Erstbesteigung durch
eine Schweizer Expedition erfolgte.
2020 war das 60 Jahre her.
Deshalb planten wir eigentlich,
letztes Jahr zu kommen,
zum Jahrestag.
Aber dann kam COVID.
* Musik im Film *
Aber es ist ein Schweizer Gipfel,
und das Besondere
an jener Expedition war,
dass sie
einen Pilatus Porter mitbrachten,
ein kleines Flugzeug
aus der Schweiz,
das das Material
zum Basislager transportierte.
(O-Ton) Die Landung ist gelungen.
Freudig gratulieren wir
unserem Piloten Ernst Sachser,
hat er damit doch
einen Weltrekord erreicht.
Schnell laden wir
unser Material aus,
während der Motor laufen gelassen
wird, damit er ja nicht einfriert.
* Majestätische Musik *
Kalt und abweisend
schaut der weiûe Berg aus,
doch verlockend zugleich.
Nichts dürfen wir vergessen.
Ein weiterer Fehlschlag
des Gipfelsturmes
könnte den endgültigen Rückzug
der Expedition bedeuten.
Es ist ein Tag des Glücks.
Der 13. Mai 1960, ein Freitag,
an dem unsere 13-köpfige
Expeditionsmannschaft
das vielen Expeditionen
verwehrt gebliebene Ziel erreicht.
Den Dhaulagiri.
Den 13. Achttausender.
* Verträumte Musik *
* Französisch *
(Übersetzung) Anfangs hätte ich
nie auch nur daran gedacht,
so etwas zu machen.
Ich habe recht spät
mit dem Bergsteigen begonnen.
2004 hatte ich einen Freund,
der davon träumte,
den Mont Blanc zu besteigen.
Ich fand das realistisch,
und wir haben es geschafft.
Ich fühlte mich sehr schnell
von der Höhe angezogen.
Die Viertausender der Alpen
genügten mir schon bald nicht mehr.
So begann ich, Urlaube um mögliche
Gipfelziele herum zu organisieren.
Ich fuhr oft nach Südamerika,
stieg auf 5'000, 6'000, 7'000 Meter.
Bis zu dieser
schicksalshaften Marke von 8'000.
Tief im Inneren hatte ich von
dem Moment an, als ich beschloss,
mich ganz den hohen Bergen
zu widmen, den Traum,
alle 14 zu machen,
aber das behielt ich für mich.
Meine Antwort war: "Ich mache
wieder einen und dann schauen wir."
Wenn man das so sagt,
setzt einen das weniger unter Druck.
Man sollte keinen Druck haben,
wenn man diese Berge besteigt.
* Verträumte Musik *
Hallo! Ich wollte nur wissen,
ob ihr ein Mikrofon vorgesehen habt.
Wenn ihr keins habt,
ist es auch nicht schlimm.
Es ist ja kein groûer Saal.
Also, bis nachher.
Ich halte heute Abend
einen Vortrag für das Fitnessstudio,
in dem ich trainiere.
Sie haben ein Jubiläum,
und ich erzähle
von meinen letzten Expeditionen.
Morgen rede ich bei Raiffeisen,
einer lokalen Bank,
und übermorgen fahre ich
für ein US-Unternehmen nach Nizza.
Die Vorträge bringen mich
durch den Winter.
Hören Sie mich gut?
Ich habe kein Mikrofon. Ich möchte
sicher sein, dass mich alle hören.
Ich komme etwas näher.
Wenn ich nicht aufpasse,
sitze ich Ihnen bald auf den Knien.
Diese Leidenschaft für
sehr groûe Höhen kam ziemlich spät.
Ich bin eine normale Frau.
Ich habe jahrelang
in Unternehmen gearbeitet.
Ich war lange in der Hotelbranche,
danach in der Kosmetikindustrie.
Ja, ja!
Sie können sich das so vorstellen:
Ich mit hohen Absätzen
und im Deuxpièces,
in der Abteilung
Vertrieb und Marketing.
Danach war ich im Finanzwesen tätig.
Ich leitete mit meinem Bruder
ein Unternehmen
für Events der Finanzbranche.
Dieses Geschäftsmodell
ist jedoch mit der Krise von 2008
komplett zusammengebrochen.
Wir haben bis 2011 überlebt
und dann die Firma geschlossen.
Und dann stand ich
vor einem leeren Blatt.
Und was heiût ein leeres Blatt?
Es gibt Zeit.
Und um einen Achttausender
zu besteigen, braucht man Zeit.
Man braucht dafür
mindestens zwei Monate.
Ich habe also
die Gelegenheit genutzt,
um einen Achttausender zu versuchen.
Und so kam es 2012
zu dieser ersten Expedition.
Ich bin dann in der gleichen Saison
nicht nur auf einen gestiegen,
sondern gleich auf zwei.
Und das war der Beginn
dieses Abenteuers.
* Spannende Musik *
* Französisch *
(Übersetzung) Die Leute denken,
nur weil man ein paar Logos
auf der Daunenjacke hat
und ins Fernsehen gekommen ist,
man sei reich.
Aber so ist es nicht.
Also das ist ein Entscheid.
Ich bedaure das keinen Moment,
im Gegenteil.
Aber die Leute haben oft
ein falsches Bild von mir.
Sie sagen:
"Ah, du hast Glück,
du kannst deine Leidenschaft leben."
Und ich: "Nein, das ist kein Glück,
das ist viel Arbeit."
* Getragene Musik *
Was ich am Ende interessant finde:
Mehrere Leben zu haben.
Es ist ein bisschen so,
wie wenn sich eine Geschichte
in einem Buch entfaltet.
Irgendwann schlieût man es,
und es beginnt eine
andere Geschichte deines Lebens.
Diese verschiedenen Leben zu leben
halte ich fast für ein Privileg.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo. Wie gehts?
Gut, und dir?
Fahren wir ins Büro.
Sangay arbeitet
100 Prozent für mich und mit mir.
Er liebt die Berge.
Das ist sehr wichtig, denn es gibt
Sherpas, die das nur als Job machen.
Aber es gibt auch die, die wirklich
dem Bergsteigen verfallen sind.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
einen Sherpa zu haben,
den man gut kennt.
Gegenseitig.
Das bedeutet mehr Sicherheit.
Man wird zu Komplizen.
Wir verbringen
viel Zeit miteinander,
deshalb ist es nicht schlecht,
wenn man sich gut versteht.
* Sie begrüûen sich auf Englisch. *
Willkommen im Himalaya.
Schön, dich wiederzusehen.
Ist alles gut?
Alles gut.
Wir sind eine groûe Expedition,
da gehe ich gerne vorbei und schaue,
ob die Dinge, die mir wichtig sind,
wirklich da sind.
Aber ich vertraue ihnen.
Es ist nur ein kleiner Check.
Das hier ist sehr gut. Schau rein.
Ihr habt groûe Zelte
für das Basislager.
Weil ihr Frauen seid.
Frauen brauchen mehr Platz.
Hallo, Max!
Wie geht es dir?
Schauen wir uns das Ess-Zelt an?
Haben wir eine Heizung?
Heizung auch.
Die Gleiche wie das letzte Mal?
- Ja.
Die Gasheizung?
Ah, das ist gut.
Sangay gehört
zu den erfahrenen Sherpas.
Deshalb ist er für unsere Expedition
an den Dhaulagiri auch Sirdar,
das heiût, er ist
für die Logistik zuständig
und leitet das Sherpa-Team.
Er hat also oft
auch diese Doppelrolle.
Auf meinen 17 Expeditionen habe ich
nur mit drei Sherpas gearbeitet.
Und ich hoffe, dass ich das Projekt
mit ihm zu Ende führen kann.
Vor zwei Wochen waren hier 700 Leute.
Ich sagte ihnen: "Wartet drei Tage."
"Dann kann ich euch sagen,
wen ich an welchen Berg schicke."
Jetzt haben einige einen fixen Job.
Die Regierung hat ja
die Quarantäne aufgehoben.
Ich denke,
es werden mehr Ausländer kommen.
Ja, weil ohne Bergsteiger,
wie kriegt man da einen Job?
Wollen wir die Plakate anschauen?
- Ja, machen wir.
Das ist "Frauen, die sich trauen".
- Ja, dies ist okay.
Unser ganzes Team.
Das groûe.
Mit den Fotos.
Es interessierte mich,
eine Expedition
nur mit Frauen zu organisieren.
Es ging mir darum, diese Expedition
mit einer Sache zu verbinden,
die mit Frauen zu tun hat.
Ich habe ein Projekt
von Terre des Hommes vorgeschlagen.
Denn ich bin ja Botschafterin
für diese Organisation.
Bei diesem Projekt geht es
um die Ausbildung von Hebammen
in den sehr armen ländlichen
Gebieten im Süden von Nepal.
* Sie begrüûen sich auf Englisch. *
* Klingelton *
Hallo, wie geht es euch?
Das ärztliche Training letztes Jahr?
Meine Rolle ist es,
für Sichtbarkeit zu sorgen.
Wenn COVID das nicht verhindert,
besuche ich die Projekte vor Ort.
Ein-, zweimal im Jahr.
Ich rede mit den Leuten,
mache Protokolle
und bringe Fotos
für die Zentrale mit.
Grüût bitte das ganze Hebammen-Team
vom letzten Jahr.
Wenn ich den Menschen hier
in der einen oder anderen Art
einen Dienst erweisen kann,
dann freut mich das.
Denn sie schauen gut zu mir.
Ich bin oft hier und bin immer
freundlich empfangen worden.
Wenn ich also
durch diese bescheidene Initiative
etwas beisteuern kann,
bin ich zufrieden.
* Französisch *
(Übersetzung) Die Situation in Nepal
ist heute, sagen wir, sauber.
Der Flughafen ist offen,
die Trekking- und Expeditionssaison
ist eröffnet,
die Genehmigungen werden erteilt.
Nepal ist also offen.
Und die Gesundheitssituation
ist gut.
Es ist heute kein Problem, sich
in Nepal zu bewegen und zu reisen.
Es gibt zwar Risiken,
weil COVID noch da ist,
aber die Zahlen sind sehr niedrig,
und die Menschen leben normal.
Vorsichtshalber muss man einen
PCR-Test machen, aber das ist alles.
* Aufwühlende Musik *
Die Folgen von COVID haben die
Bevölkerung extrem hart getroffen.
2020 war ein verlorenes Jahr.
Das hier ist ein Teil der Welt,
in dem gilt:
keine Arbeit, kein Lohn,
nichts zu essen.
So einfach ist das.
Ich bin also sehr froh, dass die
Frühjahrssaison stattfinden kann,
um das Land ein wenig zu beleben.
Das ist nicht nur gut für die Leute,
das ist notwendig.
* Beschwingte Musik *
* Hupen *
* Französisch *
(Übersetzung)
Wir fahren mit dem Jeep bis Sibang,
und von da geht es zu Fuû weiter,
das ganze Tal hinauf
bis Naura und Bagara.
Danach geht es weiter
in diesem Tal nach Dobhan Kharka
bis zum sogenannten Basislager
der Italiener.
Dort werden wir wohl
einen Tag Pause machen,
bevor wir den groûen Tag
in Angriff nehmen.
Nämlich den Aufstieg
im Wesentlichen auf dem Gletscher
bis zum Basislager des Dhaulagiri
auf 4'750 Metern.
Und das alles in vier,
fünf oder sechs Tagen,
je nachdem,
wie die Leute in Form sind.
* Fernöstliche Musik *
Einige Freunde von mir
sind für das Trekking mitgekommen.
Sie wollen mich
bis zum Basislager begleiten
und erleben, wie das ist,
so ein Basislager.
Sie werden ein, zwei Tage bleiben
und dann
nach Kathmandu zurückkehren.
Und dann ist da noch Sandra.
Sie ist Ärztin und kommt aus Genf.
Sie hat schon Expeditionen
in Südamerika gemacht,
war aber noch nie
an einem Achttausender.
Sie will auch
die Besteigung versuchen.
* Englisch *
Seid COVID, das heiût,
seit einem Jahr,
ist hier kein Tourist
mehr vorbeigekommen.
Für die Leute ist das sehr schlimm.
Sie sind sehr glücklich,
dass wir da sind.
Sie segnen unsere Expedition,
und das Geld geht an sie.
* Musik *
* Französisch *
Das Trekking ist
der Beginn des Abenteuers.
Man nähert sich dem Basislager
aus tieferen Lagen
und steigt dann langsam auf.
Das ständige Vorwärtsgehen
versetzt einen
in die Atmosphäre der Expedition.
Man durchquert Dörfer,
lernt Menschen kennen.
Sobald man auf dem Trekking ist,
fällt auch eine gewisse Spannung ab.
Das Gehen ist eine Art Kontrast,
fast notwendig.
Tee oder Kaffee?
Danke, Onkel!
* Gemütliche Musik *
(Alle) Wow!
* Sie jubeln und applaudieren. *
* Französisch *
Ich mag die Stimmung auf den Treks.
Ich mag es, jeden Tag
ein Stück weiter zu gehen.
Und es ist auch hilfreich
für die Akklimatisierung.
Die Haare.
Und das?
Das steht bei den Friseuren.
* Sie lernen Nepalesisch. *
"Muk", das ist der Mund.
Und "Kan" das Ohr.
Und das, Thsering?
* Sophie
nennt das nepalesische Wort. *
* Spannende Musik *
* Thsering
singt ein einheimisches Lied. *
* Englisch *
Im Lied sagt der Berg Matsaputsere:
"Ich bin sehr hoch."
Und Dhaulagiri antwortet:
"Du bist nicht hoch, ich bin hoch!"
Das ist das Lied
von den beiden Bergen.
* Er singt weiter. *
* Verträumte Musik *
* Gesprächsfetzen *
* Französisch *
Ich komme eigentlich
vom Wandern her.
In unserer Familie gibt es Wanderer,
keine Bergsteiger.
Seit ich klein war,
sind wir gewandert.
Als wir Kinder waren,
hatten wir eine Wohnung in
Argentiere in der Nähe von Chamonix.
Mein Bruder und ich
sind in Lausanne geboren.
Wir waren immer nahe bei den Bergen.
Und dann meine Mutter.
Sie muss
um die ganze Welt gewandert sein.
Sie hat mich auf den Geschmack
des Trekkings gebracht.
* Sie spricht mit dem Hund. *
* Sie begrüûen sich
auf Französisch. *
Das hat Klasse!
Vor allem die Position des Helms.
Nicht schlecht.
Glückliches Mädchen.
Wir sind schon sehr früh
Ski gefahren, dank unserer Eltern.
Ich war 1,5 Jahre älter als sie,
aber sie brachte es fertig,
mir überall hin zu folgen.
Ich bin damals schon gern
abseits der Pisten gefahren,
wo man nicht fahren sollte.
Aber sie war immer hinter mir.
Sie machte mir immer alles nach.
Manchmal murrte sie ein bisschen,
und tatsächlich
kam sie überall durch.
Auch danach, mit deinen Freunden.
Ich war das einzige Mädchen,
das akzeptiert war,
weil ich
auf den Skis mithalten konnte.
Da hast du deine Haltung
etwas verbessert.
Ja.
Sophie ist
ein sehr, sehr positiver Mensch.
Das hat ihr sehr geholfen bei dem,
was sie jetzt tut.
Am Anfang, wenn jemand sagt:
"Ich mache jetzt
einen Achttausender."
Das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Dann kommt ein zweiter
und ein dritter, dann ein vierter,
und schlieûlich heiût es:
"Ach ja, ich mache jetzt alle."
Da fragt man sich schon,
wohin das führt.
Man könnte sagen, es ist eigentlich
absurd, Achttausender zu besteigen.
Weil es nutzlos ist.
Nun, es steht mir nicht zu,
darüber zu urteilen,
ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Immerhin, es gibt
eine Folgerichtigkeit im Ganzen.
Und schlieûlich
erreicht sie ihre Ziele.
Ich schaue zufrieden aus im Schnee.
Damals schon.
Da war Mama 35.
So eine Wahl zu treffen
ist sehr exklusiv.
Sie schlieût viele aus
und fordert Opfer.
Kinder zu haben, eine Familie,
einen Ehemann
und gleichzeitig so etwas zu tun,
ist schon sehr, sehr kompliziert.
Ja, ich sage, mein Geliebter
ist im Moment der Himalaya.
Wir hatten einen sehr
schwierigen Fall zu bewältigen.
Nämlich die Krankheit meiner Mutter.
Seit 2012 litt sie an Alzheimer.
Die Entscheidung für die Berge
ist nicht mit der Unterstützung
eines nahen Angehörigen vereinbar.
Ganz deutlich: Mir wäre lieber
gewesen, sie hätte langsamer gemacht.
Was sie nicht tun wollte,
im Gegenteil, sie machte schneller.
Ja klar, diese Fragen stellten sich.
Aber ich hatte immer im Kopf ...
Wenn wir jetzt
von unserer Mutter reden.
Wenn sie sich dieser Situation
bewusst gewesen wäre,
bin ich nach wie vor überzeugt,
dass sie nie akzeptiert hätte,
dass ich wegen ihr verzichte.
Das ist keine Ausrede,
die ich mir einfallen lasse.
Ich bin davon überzeugt.
Sie selbst liebte die Natur so sehr.
Sie liebte es zu reisen, das war
so sehr ihre treibende Kraft,
dass sie dieses Projekt
nie gebremst hätte.
Ich beschloss, den gröûten Teil
der Pflege allein zu übernehmen.
Und Sophie machte ihren Berg
und kümmerte sich um ihre Mutter
so gut sie konnte, wenn sie da war.
* Verträumte Musik *
Wir arbeiteten fünf Jahre zusammen
und organisierten Konferenzen
für die Finanzbranche.
Regelmäûig wurde sie gebeten,
in der Öffentlichkeit zu sprechen.
Und das war immer sehr kompliziert,
ja gar unmöglich.
Und das Erstaunliche ist,
dass sich von dem Moment an,
als sie ihre Berggeschichten
öffentlich erzählte,
wie von Zauberhand
ihr Talent als Rednerin entpuppte.
Das zeigt, wie das Sprechen über das,
was man liebt, über die Leidenschaft,
einen beflügelt und einem ermöglicht,
gewisse Ängste und Blockaden
zu überwinden.
Dieser Hund heiût
Monsieur Achttausend.
Alle denken,
ich hätte ihm diesen Namen gegeben,
aber es war meine Mutter.
Er gehörte ihr,
und sie hatte ihn getauft.
Es ist eine kleine Anspielung
auf das, was ich tue.
* Musik vom Smartphone *
* Traumhafte Musik *
* Französisch *
Morgen ist ein besonderer Tag.
Es ist der letzte Tag des Trekkings,
bevor wir im Basislager ankommen.
Es ist der längste Tag,
verglichen mit dem,
was wir in den letzten Tagen
gemacht haben.
(Englisch) Wie viele Stunden?
Zwischen sechs und sieben Stunden.
Wir sind auf 3'500,
das Basislager ist auf 4'700.
1'200 Meter Aufstieg also.
Wann gehen wir los?
- Wir gehen früh.
Um sieben starten wir.
Wann sieht man
den Gipfel des Dhaulagiri?
Sieht man ihn
auf dem Weg ins Basislager?
Ich denke nicht.
Im Basislager sieht man ihn?
Vom Basislager
sieht man ihn nicht.
Nur vom Franzosenpass.
Dhaulagiri heiût "Dicker Bauch".
Deshalb kann man
den Gipfel nicht sehen.
Bereit für das Basislager?
Ja!
Wie sagt man das auf Englisch?
Attack!
* Sie lachen. *
Ich sage: "Sophie, ich mag ja Berge."
"Aber ich fahre lieber
mit den Ski runter."
Zu Fuû rauf und zu Fuû runter
gehört nicht zu meiner Philosophie.
Das ist ein Scherz zwischen uns.
Aber da raufzugehen
käme mir nie in den Sinn.
Aber ich bin neugierig und frage
mich: Was treibt sie an? Was ist es?
Die Antwort gehört letztendlich ihr.
Ich brauche sie nicht zu kennen.
* Englisch *
Ich möchte mich bei euch bedanken.
Vielleicht wird mein Traum,
einen Achttausender zu besteigen,
wahr.
Aber ohne euch würde ich es nicht
einmal bis ins Basislager schaffen.
Vielen Dank also.
Ihr seid Teil dieses Teams und
gehört zum ersten Teil dieser Reise.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns begleitet
und dass ihr uns helft.
Ihr seid so stark.
Und nochmals,
wir hätten keine Chance ohne euch.
Danke.
* Nepalesisch *
* Verträumte Musik,
Donnern einer Lawine *
* Französisch *
Mir ist sehr bewusst, dass ich
allein im Himalaya nichts ausrichte.
Ich brauche gute Träger
für unsere Ausrüstung.
Ich brauche einen guten Koch,
der gutes Essen macht,
denn wenn ich krank bin,
mache ich gar nichts.
Ich brauche Zelte, damit ich
schlafen kann, um fit zu sein.
Ich muss Vertrauen haben, in Sangay.
Das gehört alles zusammen.
Natürlich entscheide ich
am Schluss dann einiges,
aber mir gefällt die Haltung,
sich etwas zurückzunehmen
und die Bedeutung der Menschen
hervorzustreichen, die mit uns sind.
Denn ohne sie
gehen wir nirgends hin.
* Sie begrüûen sich
auf Nepalesisch und Englisch. *
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Willkommen im Basecamp.
Wie geht es dir?
Ich bin ein Freund von Sophie
seit 15, 20 Jahren.
Ich bin von Beginn an
ein Bewunderer ihrer Abenteuer.
Auf dem Weg sieht man, wie riesig
die Berge, die Gletscher sind.
Ständig hört man Steinschläge
und brechendes Eis.
Wirklich sehr, sehr beeindruckend.
Man muss sich trauen,
diese Berge zu besteigen.
Und sie geht nicht nur einmal da hin,
sie macht einen nach dem anderen.
Man muss schon eine Charakterstärke
haben, die aus dem Rahmen fällt.
* Betgesang der Sherpas *
* Französisch *
Die Puja ist eine religiöse
buddhistische Zeremonie.
Eigentlich sind alle Berge heilig,
deshalb muss man die Berggöttin
um Erlaubnis bitten,
damit man sie sicher besteigen kann.
Die Sherpas schlafen nie am Berg,
bevor die Puja
nicht stattgefunden hat.
* Betgesang *
* Französisch *
Es ist klar,
dass wir an dem Ritual teilnehmen.
Es gehört zur Expedition.
Es ist wichtig für sie,
so wird es auch wichtig für mich.
Wenn eine Puja dem Glück auf die
Sprünge helfen kann, warum nicht?
Ich nehme alles, was hilft,
damit wir Erfolg haben
und gesund zurückkommen.
* Englisch *
Die Berge sind immer gefährlich,
aber sie sind meine Arbeit.
Manchmal habe ich aber auch Angst.
Nach dem K2, 2018,
kamen wir hier her.
Damals kam einer meiner Freunde
in einer Lawine ums Leben.
Wir waren sehr mitgenommen
und brachen die Expedition dann ab.
* Mythische Musik *
* Französisch *
Ich wollte sehen, wie das Leben
in einem Basislager ist, mit Sophie.
Das Trekking war perfekt,
weil es meinem Können entsprach.
Aber mich würde es nie
nach oben ziehen.
Wir sind seit etwa
zehn Jahren befreundet.
Wir haben uns
in unseren Karrieren unterstützt.
Sie hat mir viel erzählt.
Es bewegt mich, darüber zu reden.
Denn es ist nicht
nur einfach für sie.
Ich bin immer froh,
wenn sie nach Hause kommt.
Wir wissen,
dass es nicht ohne Risiko ist.
Aber das gehört
zu dieser Entschlossenheit.
Es ist die Entscheidung jedes
Einzelnen, dieses Risiko einzugehen.
Nun, elf hat sie bereits gemacht.
Elfmal ist sie also zurückgekommen.
* Spannende Musik *
* Französisch *
Es ist klar, der Dhaulagiri
ist ein komplizierter Berg.
Er gilt als schwierig.
Er gehört nicht zu den, sagen wir,
beliebten Achttausendern.
Aber klar denke ich an die Gefahren.
Ich habe Angst vor Lawinen
und vor Gletscherspalten.
Aber das gehört zum Spiel.
Wenn das unerträglich ist,
ist es besser, nach Hause zu gehen.
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Französisch. *
Es hat mich gefreut,
dich kennenzulernen.
Bis bald.
Danke, dass ihr gekommen seid.
Es war schön mit euch.
Seid alle vorsichtig.
Aber ja!
Wieder nach Hause kommen,
um die Geschichte zu erzählen.
Wo ist Onkel?
Kommt, für ein kurzes Foto!
Danke.
Viel, viel gegessen!
Ihr habt immerhin sechs Sherpas.
Es braucht schon viele Leute.
Wie viele hatten wir?
20 bis hierher?
Wir sehen uns in Kathmandu!
Wir tanzen nicht hier,
sondern in Kathmandu.
* Sie verabschieden sich. *
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Französisch. *
* Französisch *
Wir sind bei dieser Expedition
nur Frauen.
Irgendwann kam mir die Idee und
ich begann, Frauen zu kontaktieren,
mit denen ich
auch schon geklettert bin.
Um es kurz zu machen,
sie haben praktisch alle zugesagt,
und als Ergebnis sind nun hier
acht Frauen bei dieser Expedition.
Wenn unsere Geschichten
andere Frauen inspirieren,
dann ist das groûartig.
Ich glaube, dass es für Frauen
immer noch viele Hindernisse gibt.
Sie errichten sich
eine Menge Hürden.
Berufliche, soziale, familiäre.
Deshalb lautet das Motto, das wir
unserer Expedition gegeben haben:
"Frauen, die sich trauen."
Und mit trauen meine ich nicht
aufgeblasen oder so,
sondern es geht darum,
sich die Mittel zuzugestehen.
Ich denke,
dass es im Leben wichtig ist,
so gut wie möglich zu versuchen,
sich selbst die Mittel zu geben,
um seine Träume zu verwirklichen.
* Spannende Musik *
Wir machen uns jetzt auf
zu unserer ersten
sogenannten Akklimatisierungsrunde.
Der Berg hat drei Höhenlager.
Die Idee ist,
in den Lagern zu schlafen,
damit sich der Körper anpasst
und zusätzliche
rote Blutkörperchen produziert,
um den Sauerstoffmangel
auszugleichen.
Darum geht es
bei der Akklimatisierung.
Wir werden im Lager 1 schlafen,
das bereits auf 5'900 Metern ist.
Das sind
1'000 Höhenmeter auf einmal,
was recht viel ist in dieser Höhe.
Wenn wir uns gut fühlen,
gehen wir morgen ins Lager 2 hoch.
Wenn es uns nicht so gut geht,
machen wir wohl zwei Nächte
in Lager 1 und eine in Lager 2.
Aber die Idee ist,
drei Nächte am Berg zu verbringen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Es ist so heiû!
* Französisch *
Ich gehe seit 25 Jahren in die Berge,
und ich unterrichte Höhenmedizin.
Aber es kann ja nicht nur
um die Vermittlung von Theorie gehen.
Aber ich muss sagen, jetzt,
wo ich hier bin, ist alles anders.
Ich finde das hier sehr schwierig.
Ich wusste, dass der Körper
an seine Grenzen kommt,
habe es aber so nie wirklich erlebt.
* Spannende Musik *
* Französisch *
Mir gefällt die Anstrengung,
die es braucht, um hochzukommen.
Es ist eine Genugtuung,
im Höhenlager anzukommen.
Das Gefühl zu haben,
dass man es kann.
Aber solange ich nicht mit beiden
Füûen auf dem Gipfel stehe
und wieder unten bin, weiû ich
nicht, ob ich dazu in der Lage bin.
Den Kopf gerade, den Blick da rüber.
* Französisch *
Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist,
das ist eine normale Person
mit einem nicht normalen Projekt.
Sophie hat nicht
den Körper einer Athletin.
Aber wie viele, die das machen,
hat sie eine physiologische
Veranlagung für groûe Höhen.
Ein Vorteil, klar, aber körperlich
ist sie eine normale 50-Jährige.
Wir mussten nie wirklich viel tun,
damit sie das schafft.
Es gibt kein Geheimnis
oder gar Wunderrezept.
Man muss vernünftig sein
und auf sich selbst hören.
Man muss seinen Körper gut kennen,
die Dinge nicht überstürzen wollen.
Deshalb gehe ich
ein wenig nach der Theorie,
ein Schritt nach dem anderen
oder ein Gipfel nach dem anderen,
dann schauen wir weiter.
Wichtig ist gute Erholung.
Und dann ist da noch
diese Disziplin,
die ich mir zu eigen gemacht habe
und das ganze Jahr über lebe.
In Bezug auf Ernährung, Sport,
genügend Schlaf,
Stress zu vermeiden,
nicht übermüdet abreisen.
Und dann alles, was wir hier machen.
Es ist ein Ganzes.
Und es scheint gut zu funktionieren.
Ich will es also nicht groû ändern.
Ihr Dickschädel und ihr Wille.
Ich denke, es ist die Willenskraft.
Sie macht den Unterschied
zwischen Menschen,
die körperlich zu etwas fähig sind,
und denen, die es tatsächlich tun.
Irgendwann übernimmt der Kopf.
In den Höhen kommt der Moment,
da spricht vieles dagegen
weiterzugehen,
aber der Kopf treibt einen voran.
Und manchmal ist es vernünftig
zu gehen, und der Kopf sagt Nein.
Dann wissen wir nicht,
ob es gut gelaufen wäre oder nicht.
So ist das eben.
* Französisch *
Sie hat ihre persönlichen Gründe,
warum sie das tut.
Aber sie ist im Einklang mit sich
selbst und mit den Entscheidungen,
die sie in der Höhe treffen muss.
Deshalb wird sie ihr Ziel erreichen
und ich mag es, mit ihr zu arbeiten.
Sie denkt alles durch,
bleibt auf dem Boden
und macht keine verrückten Dinge.
* Französisch *
In meiner Jugend habe ich viel
klassisches Ballett gemacht.
Das war der Motor
während meiner ganzen Kindheit.
Ich bin sehr weit gekommen,
und mein Traum war,
Primaballerina zu werden.
Und dann hatte ich in dem Jahr,
als ich vortanzen sollte,
zwei medizinische Probleme.
Eine Blinddarmentzündung
und schwere Rückenprobleme,
die mich für ein Jahr
in ein Korsett zwangen.
Als ich endlich wieder
in der Lage war zu tanzen,
hatte ich das Niveau nicht mehr.
Es war ein echtes Lebensprojekt,
auf das ich verzichten musste.
Als es mit dem Tanzen aus war,
hätte ich mich am liebsten begraben.
Heute denke ich,
dass diese Jahre des Balletts
mich mental geformt haben.
Also ja, vielleicht kann ich deshalb
das körperliche Leiden
besser akzeptieren als andere.
Ich bin kein Masochist.
Aber ich funktioniere
auf eine Art und Weise,
die es mir erlaubt,
das möglich zu machen.
Glaube ich. Ich weiû es nicht.
Ich muss einen Psychiater fragen,
vielleicht hat der eine Antwort.
Es ist nicht einfach,
auf Achttausender zu steigen.
Wenn man mich nach
dem einfachsten fragt, sage ich:
"Es gibt keinen einfachen."
Es gibt vielleicht einige, die
weniger schwierig sind als andere,
aber es gibt nichts,
was daran einfach wäre.
Für mich gibt es zwei wesentliche
Eigenschaften im Himalaya:
Geduld und Verzicht.
Hat man keine Geduld,
begibt man sich in Gefahr.
Und kann man nicht verzichten,
wird man zu sehr leiden.
* Sie spricht mit dem Hund. *
Mein wichtigster Antrieb
ist das Vergnügen,
nicht die Leistung.
Also bitte nicht falsch verstehen,
ich tue alles, was in meiner Macht
steht, um zum Gipfel zu kommen.
Aber wenn man
diese ganze Welt da nicht mag,
das Leben im Basislager,
wenn man nicht warten kann,
denn wir sind nichts
in diesen Bergen.
Wir sind nur Ameisen, die
durch ein kleines Loch schlüpfen,
wenn der Himmel es zulässt.
Aber der Himmel
im Sinne der Meteorologie.
Es gibt nichts Mystisches.
Also das ist auch möglich,
es gibt Menschen, die da
auf der Suche sind nach etwas.
Ich bin nicht auf der Suche.
Ich sage immer, ich mache weiter,
solange ich
körperlich dazu fähig bin,
solange ich das Geld habe
und ich unterstützt werde.
Und solange ich Spaû habe.
Denn an dem Tag, an dem ich
in den Flieger steige und sage:
"Jetzt muss ich noch einen abhaken."
Ich kenne mich,
das funktioniert nicht.
* Französisch *
(Sandra) Ich war gestern
wirklich erschöpft,
und wir waren nicht mal
auf 6'000 Metern.
Ich schlief den ganzen Nachmittag.
In der Nacht hatte ich Kopfschmerzen,
heute Morgen auch.
Und ja ...
diesen Zustand kenne ich nicht.
Ich zweifle, ob ich
zum richtigen Zeitpunkt hier bin,
um eine solche Besteigung
zu versuchen.
Und das ...
Und dass ich vielleicht nicht
die Kraft habe, um höher zu steigen.
Meine Gedanken drehen sich darum,
dass ich runtergehen möchte.
Ich möchte nach Hause.
Ich muss akzeptieren,
dass das hier nicht für mich ist.
Du musst dir Zeit geben.
Du wirst dich erholen,
du wirst wieder weitergehen.
Du machst eine Zwischenetappe
auf dem Plateau.
Steig in zwei Tagen
statt in einem auf.
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten.
- Ich weiû nicht, ob ich das will.
Das ist eine andere Frage.
Darüber muss ich mir klar werden.
Okay, Frühstück für euch
und dann los.
(Sandra) Das gilt in den Alpen.
Das gilt in den Alpen,
aber hier noch mehr.
Man kann sich in den Bergen
nicht verstecken.
Wenn ich bereits jetzt so leide,
wie soll ich dann höher steigen?
Jedes Bein wiegt 1'000 Kilo.
Das Teil am Seil soll dir helfen.
Aber manchmal friert es ein,
sodass es gar nicht hilft.
Der Sherpa wird dich nicht
nach oben schieben.
Das muss man alles selbst tun.
(Englisch) Okay.
Lagba wird führen,
und wir gehen langsam runter.
Okay.
- Keine Eile.
(Sandra) Ich kenne Sophie
seit etwa fünf Jahren.
Ich habe groûen Respekt vor dem,
was sie macht.
Es gibt in der Welt der hohen Berge
diese ganze Debatte über Sauerstoff,
kein Sauerstoff,
Sherpas, Seile usw.
Aber Tatsache ist,
und das weiû ich jetzt,
man kann Sauerstoff haben,
Sherpas, Seile,
und es ist immer noch schwierig.
Aber es gibt halt solche Momente,
in denen einem Flügel wachsen
und man denkt: "Warum nicht ich?"
Aber das ist, bevor man hier ist.
Ich sage immer:
Man muss mit leerem Kopf gehen.
Alles, was dir im Kopf dreht
und dich runterzieht, ist nicht gut.
All die kleinen Fäden,
die dich heimziehen,
ins Basislager
oder sonst irgendwohin,
legen dir Hindernisse in den Weg.
Sie hindern dich daran,
nach oben zu gehen.
Oder sie machen es noch schwieriger
als es ohnehin schon ist.
Ich muss irgendwann
einen Schnitt machen,
damit ich mich auf den Berg
konzentrieren kann.
Denn das sind groûe Brocken.
* Traumhafte Musik *
* Englisch *
Schau! Annapurna.
Ja.
- Ganz nahe.
Von hier sieht man sie gut.
Ein kalter Wind von Nordwesten.
* Englisch *
Wir müssen unseren Plan ändern.
Ich habe einen sehr schlechten
Wetterbericht bekommen.
Wir wollten drei Nächte machen,
aber das geht nicht.
Ab drei Uhr nachts
ist ein groûer Sturm
mit viel Wind und Schnee angesagt.
Wir gehen besser runter.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Englisch *
Basislager, Lager 2.
Keine Antwort.
Seit letzter Nacht
stürmt es nun tatsächlich.
Und nur Naoko und ihr Sherpa haben
beschlossen, im Lager 2 zu bleiben.
Wir haben im Moment
keine Nachrichten von ihnen.
Ich glaube, die Batterien
ihres Funkgeräts sind leer.
Das ist beunruhigend,
denn schon hier, auf 4'700 Metern,
ist ein schrecklicher Wind
mit viel Schnee.
Ich stelle mir vor, dass es
auf 6'500 noch viel schlimmer ist.
* Englisch *
Ist ihr Satellitentelefon hier
oder oben?
Ich weiû nicht, kein Kontakt.
* Französisch *
Sie sitzt wirklich da oben fest.
Denn man muss die Spur neu machen.
Die Seile finden, um abzusteigen.
Man muss den Weg finden.
Ich würde sagen,
bei dem Nebel und Sturm,
sogar schon hier im Basislager,
ist es fast unmöglich.
* Spannende Musik *
* Englisch *
Für zwei Personen
ist das nicht möglich.
Sechs, sieben Leute
können eine Spur machen,
das ist möglich, aber nicht zwei.
* Donnern *
* Englisch *
Habt ihr ihre Satellitennummer?
- Ja.
Wir gehen jetzt zu Naokos Zelt
und schauen,
ob das Satellitentelefon da ist
oder nicht.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Überall Schnee.
Das ist ihres.
- Dann sind sie vielleicht am Leben.
Wenn morgen das Wetter gut ist,
rufen wir den Heli und gehen rauf.
Wenn ihr Satellitentelefon
schon hier ist.
Hoffentlich gehts ihnen gut.
Wenn es da oben auch so stürmt,
sind ihre Überlebenschancen
vielleicht bei 20 Prozent.
* Verträumte Musik *
* Französisch *
Ich habe mich
auf Wetterprognosen in den Bergen
und vor allem im Himalaya
spezialisiert.
Der Himalaya, das heiût, Pakistan,
Nepal, China und Bhutan.
Und bei Sophie
wird es der Dhaulagiri sein.
Wir reden hier von sehr groûen Höhen.
Auf dem Gipfel
kann es -30, -35° sein.
Und es kann extrem heftig stürmen.
Dann geht man natürlich nicht.
Aber es gibt Winde mit über 200 km/h.
Wenn ich auf ein Wetterfenster warte,
fünf Tage und kein Wind,
das passiert nie.
Oder das ist sehr, sehr, sehr selten.
Man muss also Risiken eingehen.
Die Risikobereitschaft
hängt auch davon ab,
wie stark die Bergsteiger sind.
Wenn ich Bergsteiger habe,
die auf den Achttausender-Gipfeln
nicht sehr stark sind,
werde ich
keine groûen Risiken eingehen.
Nun, bei Sophie, die ist solide,
die behauptet sich.
Hallo, Yan.
Hallo, Sophie.
Wie gehts?
Gehts gut?
Nicht schlechter, und dir?
Es geht.
Setzen wir uns an den Tisch?
Reden wir
über den nächsten Streich?
Vertrauen ist alles.
Wenn ich an dem zweifle,
was er mir sagt,
wenn wir in den Hochlagern sind,
mache ich
ein paar Schritte aus meinem Zelt,
drehe mich um und gehe heim,
das funktioniert nicht.
Wer in einem solchen Fall
das Sagen hat, das ist Yan.
Denn es ist Yan, der das Go gibt.
Es ist fast wie ein Befehl.
"Los, jetzt musst du gehen."
Ich folge dem, was er mir sagt.
Ja, wir arbeiten gut zusammen,
weil du gut zuhörst.
Ich habe auch andere Alpinisten,
die nicht zuhören,
und dann funktioniert es nicht.
Und da die intellektuelle Kapazität
in groûer Höhe um 80 Prozent abnimmt,
bleibt dir nur das, worüber wir
12 Stunden vorher gesprochen haben.
Ich denke,
es bleiben Worte hängen wie:
"Ja, du kannst gehen, aber du
darfst nicht zu spät zurückkommen."
"Und wenn es vorher zuzieht,
dann geht man nicht."
Es bleiben dir
nur diese Art von Sätzen. - Genau.
Mit dieser Logik,
wenn das Vertrauen da ist,
wollen wir das Risiko
so gering wie möglich halten.
Das ist immerhin
das Ziel des Ganzen.
Wenn wir das Wetterrisiko reduzieren,
ist das schon mal nicht schlecht.
Prognosen für ein Tennisturnier
zu machen ist nicht sehr spannend.
Ja, es bleibt
zwangsläufig ein Risiko.
Bergsteiger gehen Risiken ein
und ich auch.
Das ist es, was mir gefällt,
aber wir sind auch nicht ganz normal.
* Spannende Musik *
* Traumhafte Musik *
* Englisch *
Wegen dem schlechten Wetter
hatten sie zwei Tage kein Signal.
Heute Morgen
hat sie Mingma angerufen.
Wie hat sie angerufen?
- Mit dem Handy.
Es geht ihnen gut?
- Ja, gut.
Habt ihr das gehört?
Was?
Es geht ihnen gut.
Sie haben Mingma angerufen.
Nein!
Wann haben sie angerufen?
Heute Morgen hatten sie Empfang
mit dem Handy
und haben Mingma angerufen.
Aber sie müssen
trotzdem gerettet werden.
Wollen sie oder nicht?
- Sie wollen.
Sie können nicht. Zu viel Schnee.
Der Helikopter
wird mit der Longline kommen.
Weil es zu viel Schnee hat?
- Ja.
Gute Nachrichten.
Ich machte mir wirklich Sorgen.
Und ich wollte nicht,
dass diese Expedition so beginnt.
Für mich bedeutet das
wahrscheinlich das Ende.
Ich schaue,
ob mich der Heli mitnimmt oder nicht.
Ich bin froh, dass ich
mit guten Nachrichten abreise.
Wenn ich denn heute gehe.
* Donnern und Tosen *
* Spannende Musik *
* Französisch *
Der Wetterbericht war ziemlich klar,
und ich gab ihn ans Team weiter.
Und auch die anderen,
das internationale Team,
das spanische Team,
alle, die am Berg waren,
gingen runter, auûer ihnen.
Ich bin die Expeditionsleiterin,
weil ich die Expedition
organisiert habe.
Aber jeder kann auf dem Berg machen,
was er will.
Und Naoko wollte oben bleiben
und ihre Rotation durchziehen.
Ich habe keine Macht
über ihre Entscheidungen.
Es geht mir natürlich
besonders nahe,
wenn es Menschen betrifft,
die ich kenne.
Wenn sie in Gefahr sind,
ist man immer in Sorge.
Die Folge von dem allen ist,
dass sie nicht nur sich
in Gefahr bringt,
sondern auch ihren Sherpa und alle,
die sie retten gehen.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd. Schade.
Man muss die Dinge
hinter sich lassen.
Es ergibt keinen Sinn,
sich darüber aufzuregen.
Es war ein Fehler,
menschliches Versagen,
aber jeder macht Fehler.
Auf jeden Fall hat es
vier Hubschrauberrotationen
und viel Geld gekostet,
aber alle sind in Sicherheit,
und das ist das Wichtigste.
* Japanisch *
(Sandra) Es ist schon sehr schade.
Das war nicht mein Berg.
Lass von dir hören.
Vor allem du.
Ich werde mich in Genf
an den See legen
und die Füûe hochlagern.
Pass auf dich auf.
Ich wiederhole mich.
Man muss nach Hause kommen,
um erzählen zu können.
* Französisch *
Ich denke, sie hat im Kopf sehr
schnell abgeschaltet und das wars.
Diese groûen Berge bedeuten
zu viel Engagement, so viel Leiden.
Es braucht viele Dinge,
die zusammenpassen müssen.
Wenn du nicht supermotiviert bist,
ergibt das keinen Sinn.
Ich denke,
sie hat richtig entschieden.
* Traumhafte Musik *
Et voila!
Hey!
- Hey, Sophie.
Das war anstrengend heute.
(Sherpa) Willkommen!
- Danke!
Wir sind jetzt wieder im Lager 1.
Ganz schöner Sturm.
Die Sherpas brauchten drei Tage,
um den Weg ins Camp zu spuren.
Das ist eine riesige Arbeit.
Jetzt muss man eine Plattform bauen,
das Zelt aufstellen,
Wasser sieben, trinken,
es ist also noch nicht fertig.
* Englisch *
Ja!
Abendessen.
Danke.
* Traumhafte Musik *
* Französisch *
Ich gehe bei meinen Expeditionen
immer gleich vor.
Ich arbeite mit Sangay
und es gibt ein Team, das vorgeht
und den Weg zu den Camps eröffnet.
Und ich plane immer Sauerstoff ein,
den ich bis zum letzten Lager
mitnehme und je nach Bedarf benutze.
Es gibt sehr starke Alpinisten,
die neue Routen eröffnen
und technisch
viel besser sind als ich.
Ich habe mich für die Normalrouten
an den Achttausendern entschieden,
mit diesem ganzen Umfeld.
Zum Glück ist man immer noch frei,
es so zu machen, wie man will.
Und es stimmt, man kann
allein eine Erstbegehung machen,
oder auf eine Expedition gehen,
mit fünf eigenen Sherpas
und sechs Sauerstoffflaschen.
Aber es spielt weniger eine Rolle,
welche Mittel man einsetzt,
um aufzusteigen,
als viel mehr,
dass man transparent ist und klar.
Es gibt nicht
das Gute oder das Schlechte.
* Funkmeldungen, spannende Musik *
* Nepalesisch *
* Englisch *
Das ist unsere zweite Nacht
im Lager 2.
Es war recht windig, recht kalt.
Schlecht geschlafen.
Jetzt gehen wir runter.
Wenn das Wetter so klar bleibt,
kann das Vorbereitungsteam
vielleicht hoch
und bis zum Lager 3
mit Fixseilen sichern.
Und wir können
beim nächsten Aufstieg
einen Gipfelversuch starten.
Hoffen wir.
* Französisch *
Die Akklimatisierung
ist jetzt abgeschlossen.
Das bedeutet,
dass der Körper bereit ist.
Der Körper und der Kopf.
Das ist schon mal sehr wichtig.
Da es drei Höhenlager gibt,
plus den Gipfel,
plus einen Reservetag
und den Rückweg,
braucht es mindestens fünf Tage,
sagen wir, stabiles Wetter.
* Donnern *
Ich träume von einem Dal Bhat
und einer Dusche. Das ist alles.
Mich umziehen, weil ich stinke.
Ein gutes Dal Bhat essen
und eine Dusche nehmen,
solange die Sonne noch da ist.
Darf ich gehen?
* Traumhafte Musik *
* Spannende Musik *
* Englisch *
Wir haben hier
ungefähr 12 COVID-Tests.
Vielleicht können wir es schaffen,
aber wir brauchen mehr Tests.
Ich weiû, das ist schwierig,
aber das ist dein Job.
Du musst sie finden.
* Französisch *
Es gibt zwei Evakuierungen.
So ist das jetzt also.
Wir haben COVID im Basislager.
Das löst groûe Sorge aus.
Alle sind sehr angespannt.
Wir werden sehen.
Jeder Tag sein Leid,
wie wir auf Französisch sagen.
* Nepalesisch *
* Englisch *
Das Wetter in Kathmandu
ist nicht gut.
Der Heli kann nicht fliegen.
In der Höhe
ist COVID sehr gefährlich.
Weil es hier sehr kalt ist.
Sie haben Husten, Fieber
und sie sind krank.
Stärker krank.
Zurückgehen wäre besser,
aber das Wetter ist nicht gut heute.
Was soll man machen?
* Von überall her hört man Husten. *
* Französisch *
Das ist kein Vergnügen,
diese Krankheit.
Ich bin so selten krank, dass es
immer ein bisschen seltsam ist.
Ich glaube,
das war noch nicht alles.
Die Fälle werden sich
im Basislager ausbreiten.
Das kam wie ein Tornado,
eindrücklich.
Viele Sherpas sind krank.
Wahnsinn, all die Hindernisse
bei diesem Projekt.
Wenn es nicht sein soll,
soll es nicht sein.
Als wir die Firma hatten,
mein Bruder und ich, sagten wir:
Wenn ein Dossier faul ist,
ist es faul.
Wenns faul ist, dann ist es faul.
Es ist schade,
wegen dem Projekt mit den Frauen.
Schade, wegen vielem anderen auch.
Aber was will man,
die Krankheit ist stärker als wir.
Sie nagelt dich auf den Boden.
Da gibts nicht viel dazu zu sagen.
Wir haben nie
mit so einer Situation gerechnet.
Und plötzlich haben wir COVID.
* Melancholisch-düstere Musik *
So traurig.
Ich kam viermal, kein Gipfel.
Immer noch nicht.
Nächstes Jahr.
* Von irgendwo
hört man Gesprächsfetzen. *
* Melancholische Musik *
* Französisch *
Alle sind von dieser indischen
Variante überrascht worden.
Vermutlich hat sie jemand vom Team
mit herauf gebracht.
Es ergibt keinen Sinn,
dagegen anzukämpfen.
Man muss es akzeptieren.
Es ist wie das Erdbeben 2015.
Oder die Lawine am K2 2016.
Und 2021 ist es COVID.
Es sind Ereignisse,
die von auûen kommen,
und es war unmöglich
weiterzumachen.
Das gehört zum Bergsteigen
im Himalaya.
Geduld und Verzicht.
Das sage ich ja schon immer.
* Englisch *
Beim vierten Mal der Gipfel!
Ich bin so glücklich!
Danke, Sangay!
Ich denke an meine Mutter.
Ich liebe dich.
Dhaulagiri, 8'167 Meter!
Ich habe versprochen,
dich hier rauf zu bringen.
Wir sind da!
Untertitelung: Iyuno Media Group
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2021